first off get that pan really nice and
hot these are sterling steaks sear it in
the pan
will let fat on I'll add flavor salt and
pepper cover tablespoons of olive oil in
pan nice and hot
hold the steak and lay it in always lay
our way through the pan a little shake
and it stops the steak from sticking
looking for color if it sticks it's
gonna burn while the steaks are cooking
and go with my super quick marinade now
two tablespoons of miso paste yes sir
fermented soybean that gives a really
nice sort of rich sweetness tablespoon
of sugar couple tablespoons rice wine
that gives it a really nice vinegary
kick tell the tablespoons of olive oil
salt and pepper
I'm looking for a nice sort of thick
rich marinade
moenay done it's time to turn the stakes
saw the pan and give the space bill
based what we're doing every time is
just adding more and more flavor take
your tongs and sort of lift the steak on
its fat really melt for that fat down
pop of the gas
tell them out just take your knife it's
all that fat there just slice that off
no one either now in the marinade useful
tacos are one of Mexico's most popular
street foods that we made from beef pork
chicken or fish and are loaded up with
amazing sauces and spices now I want
something sort of pickly cabbage these
are Chinese cabbages slice it in half
look at it really crisp and really tasty
I'm going to slice that into quarters
and then just shred it and take your
time
take a cabbage hair and you think it's
sort of braised over cooked cabbage
nothing worse but I tack oh you want
freshness and it'll season chili flakes
they sort of discreetly give it a little
bit of heat you'll touch of rice wine
vinegar you haven't got that fresh lemon
juice small drop of toasted sesame seed
oil give that a really good mix now I
need something to sort of bring it
together we take some wasabi paste those
hot very spicy
I sort of thumbnail size I'm gonna mix
that a cup of tablespoons of mayonnaise
you give that a really good mix these
are basic corn tortilla
the trick is just sort of color them and
then shape them actually place it on a
gas ring use some tongs so it's not to
burn yourself
you can also toast your tacos in a
frying pan from there I'm just going to
place it on the rolling pin literally 30
seconds as it cools down the great thing
about serving tacos is people can fill
them themselves just the way they want
them cabbage just squeezed out wet
marinade nice rustic little Mountain
mayonnaise on what you see how soft and
delicious and almost sort of melting in
the mouth texture we've got this amazing
sirloin so that really nice sear on the
outside
she asked nicely pink in the middle
start off with my crispy shell back of
the spoon with the wasabi mayonnaise
inside taco and just sprinkle a
delicious pickled cabbage and then just
start lining my tucker three or four
slices touch more for my spicy mayo that
is how I'd make the perfect taco
you
honey glazes the pork beautifully
counteracts against the left spice in
their fresh lemon juice over and that
just gives that extra acidic kick